[Applause]
[Music]
the biden administration is leaning
towards ten thousand dollars in student
loan forgiveness for more on this issue
and a look at the best pass forward
let's bring in o'leary ventures chairman
kevin o'leary he's also a cnbc
contributor kevin what do you think
about the plan for student loan
forgiveness
becky i'm trying to find merit in this
proposed policy and i can't
this is policy born in hell and i'll
tell you why
nobody wins
what do you say to people for
generations now i've realized like
everybody does that education is not
a right it's a privilege you make a
decision as a young adult to pursue an
education for a wide range of reasons
including advancing yourself and your
career and your salary etc and that's
proven to work but you take on
responsibilities including student debt
so what do you tell people generations
past that have actually paid back their
debt how about the people that are
working so hard to get scholarships to
excel what do you tell them don't bother
it's free how about the people that
never had the opportunity to go to
college about 12 percent of the
population has student debt the other 88
have to pay for them
and then think about the politics of
this and this is what i find so
extraordinary average salary in america
58 000 depending on regions you're
telling these people this is a big
problem meanwhile you can't fill up your
car chicken costs 48 more and this is at
the top of the agenda for the president
can you imagine
this is manna from heaven for the
republican party in all these tight
races coming into the midterms this is
going to be the issue that they get to
campaign on
why why would you do this this is a
really really bad idea and brings into
question who is advising biden who are
his closest advisors what planet are
they on it's not the planet earth we
just printed four and a half trillion
dollars over the last two and a half
years we have helped everybody this has
nothing to do with gender or race it has
to do with equity it's simply not fair
this idea is unamerican by any measure
everybody's uncomfortable with this i
can't find anybody that likes this idea
and i know and i get i'm guessing right
now
within the white house as they discuss
this going into the midterms somebody's
going to say mr president let's punt
this this is a horrible idea let's deal
with it on the other side imagine the
membership of the democratic party
fighting these races they're razor close
and giving their competitor
this manna from heaven this is crazy
it's just politically insane it's it's a
kamikaze idea now is the wrong time for
this and by the way there's never going
to be a good time for this you this is
un-american there's no free money that
doesn't work this way it's unfair to
people that didn't go to college you're
asking people it never went to college
to pay for this it comes off their
income tax it's just wrong
hey mr wonderful here
the newspaper what's the news senators
propose cryptocurrency bill okay
now why do you care about policy let me
tell you why you care about policy
you want the big money to come into
crypto that's the institutional and
sovereign money and there's not they're
not going to come into it until this
happens it's a policy right here this is
good news proposed policy now
why i like this is basically they're
laying out the framework for how this
could work this is proposed bill by
senator cynthia lummus and
what's great about his bipartisan you
actually have a democrat in here
kirsten gillibrand
the two of them are working on it
together now what's terrific about this
is
they're listening
they'll actually take a meeting
these are good senators that's exactly
what i did i flew down to washington
i sat down with her i asked her about
this bill because i care
i want there to be policy i'm not a
crypto cowboy i'm compliant i want to
bring sovereign wealth and pension plans
into this so prices will appreciate and
stabilize you know for all the
excitement about crypto we're only 1.2
trillion and that's a nothing burger
nothing
800 billion who cares that may sound
like a lot of money it's nothing in the
context of what it could be if we can
get this worked out so i like this
now let's listen to the interview from
you know i just did this so why don't
you listen to what she says here this is
really interesting stuff she's got
something going on here hey everybody mr
wonderful here this is an episode of mr
wonderful ghost to washington and i'll
tell you why i'm here i'm here with
senator lewis this is very important
we're talking about the policy for
crypto now this is getting exciting
because we're finally getting some
policy and this is bipartisan
you've got a democratic senator with you
now right senator kirsten gillibrand
from new york is my lead co-sponsor how
often do you see both sides of the table
anymore here in washington pretty well
never anymore right not that i want to
be negative i'm hoping that it'll become
more common but it's been pretty rare
for the last 15 months or so it's just
been wonderful to work with senator
gillibrand she's been a securities
lawyer she's in you know the largest
capital market
in the world in new york
i come from a state that really was the
leader the pioneer in legislation to
deal with digital assets so it's really
been a great combination so let's go
back to your motivation to get into this
storm because crypto has been very
controversial even in the last few weeks
around stable coins but let's talk about
this very broad base bill this
bipartisan bill what's the motivation
well the motivation is to find the sweet
spot between allowing innovation but
having a regulatory framework that
everyone understands the rules of the
road and can work with
it's been called as you know the wild
wild west
it's an untamed territory where no one
knows what the regulatory environment is
going to look like
we want to provide some structure to the
regulatory framework so we're going to
lay digital asset regulation on top of
our existing regulatory structure for
traditional assets
so
let's talk about the different asset
classes and just give us the 30 000 foot
to you let's talk about the grand daddy
bitcoin
your pro bitcoin i'm going to assume
yeah very much so and uh bitcoin will be
a commodity so it will be thank you for
saying that oh my goodness take a moment
of silence on that
that is fantastic that's fantastic so it
will be under the commodity futures
trading commission so it will uh
that will be the place where the spot
market the futures market
and other commodity type
digital assets will be regulated what
about new innovations like polygon or
salon or other chains that are not
ethereum how do you treat those in this
bill we use the harry test which is a
traditional
court decision that's been used for
years to
determine what is a security
and we've looked at every circuit court
case
that has uh commented on the how we test
updated the howie definition to
incorporate uh every single court case
that has interpreted the howie test and
now that will be codified or turned into
law in this bill so anything that would
have been a security
under the howie test will continue to be
a security and the others will be
commodities okay so if
the idea is that there's policy in place
to do the test and then give some
certainty in the market let's go to an
area that's been very very controversial
in the last six weeks stable coins yes
you spoke recently uh here in washington
at the commerce digital commerce
you were there were a lot of people
asking questions about stable coins
because luna went to zero it was an
algorithmic stable coin not backed by
the us dollar correct there are stable
coins back by the u.s
do you contemplate that in the bill
yes
our bill would provide that
it would have to be backed by one of two
things either a hundred percent asset
backed by hard assets or
uh by uh fdic insurance so a financial
institution that is fdic insured could
issue stable coins as could a non-fdic
entity as long as it's backed by more
than 100
uh assets now i'll tell you why this is
so important
of all the attributes of this bill to me
as an investor this is what i care about
the most
if the us dollar is going to remain as a
default currency globally we need a u.s
backed stablecoin because as a payment
system it's so far more efficient than
what we're doing transferring between
different geographies different
jurisdictions different countries trying
to figure out fx currency and the ach
the days it takes to move money exactly
and all of this works with total
transparency this bill contemplates
giving us finally something
because i'm not using the chinese stable
coin right nor is anybody else i know
but if we got this then i could really
do transactions just in real estate in
different countries all the things we
could do with this so i applaud you for
that
i think now the challenge is selling
this monster this is a big bill right
big bill what's the name what happens
next well there are four committees in
the senate that have jurisdiction over
this bill um ag because they huge yeah
they oversee the cftc banking because
that's sec very huge yeah the tax
components would go to finance right the
cyber security components would go to
the intelligence committee and when you
walk the halls working that file
what kind of bond you're getting i'm
getting good reception from the senate
membership and it's because they know
that senator gillibrand and i have been
working on this bill they know it's
comprehensive they know what elements
we're covering so
this is going to be the base bill will
it look like it does today it could look
very different in a few months after all
the committees have finished their work
the important thing is they're all going
to be working from this draft this will
be the base bill some want to chop it up
into three pieces are you cool with that
i am because of the jurisdictional um
because i'm walking these halls too and
i'm listening to everybody they're
excited finally we've got something
coming right the the buzz is that we'll
deal with this after the midterms
in the new year is that realistic well i
think that we want to i think that is
realistic but i also think that we'll
try to have some committees that wish to
move forward with hearings to do so
for example that might be true in ag
because of the cfdc
importance
in this bill
we'll probably be working somewhat with
the sec as well well i'm sure you'll be
hearing from them and is there a bit of
a jurisdictional tension between these
different parties who controls this
stuff
there may be but the good news is in my
communications with
the
leadership at both the cftc and the sec
they're very open
to working with us on this bill we have
open door policies we've been anxious to
get their feedback and uh
we
it is going to be divided there are a
lot as you know there's there are tens
of thousands of
uh cryptocurrencies
and some of them need full disclosure
and the sec is actually really good at
disclosure
so there will be a light touch
disclosure provision in this bill that
gives uh
the sec direction uh that will help
consumers make informed choices now let
me give you some good news i know we
have to rap but i travel the world
because i service sovereign pension
plans
they love what you're doing they want
policy and they really want it around
bitcoin which they're very interested in
putting an allocation to i mean it is
the granddaddy if you could focus on the
big market cap coins first but we would
love you even more but anyways that's
the update from washington isn't this
fantastic
really from the senators making it
happen this is terrific
now where can they find out more
well they can find out more on my
website
in the senate and senator gillibrand's
website in the senate if they have
comments
through those same avenues we will
direct uh people who want to provide us
input
to the place to send it don't be bashful
we'll be back soon thank you so much
thank you this is wonderful
policy
if you like that video wait did you see
my next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe